[Music]
matthew is in columbia south carolina hi
matthew welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi chris uh honor to speak to
you guys i'm a long time listener and
i'm excited to actually ask you my
question
okay um so i i live currently in
columbia i'm from charlotte um and i
moved down here with my my fiance's from
the area
and apparently we i have a home and
we're staying together
and right now with the corner of our
situation going on
i've been working from home and i went
back to working um at my job site
um so i'm kind of on on edge about how
my the security of my job currently um
and with the home that we have
that we purchased i'm just trying to
think of best options of how to make
sure i can take care of the home and
i know you speak emergency fund but kind
of want to get more advice about
something they're going through
as far as keeping that foundation
together yeah when you're getting
married
uh december 31st why
we wanted a new year's eve wedding to
try to celebrate the new year so that's
kind of what we wanted to kind of go
from there
yeah you don't own the house you're in
together she owns it right
no i we i own it we all together you own
it together both your names are on the
yeah well deed name's on the beach she's
on the
yeah we're both gonna be yeah but what's
on these oh crap
okay um and you own the house from
before the relationship back in
charlotte right
no so i moved to columbia and i
purchased the house and i moved to
columbia oh okay
so do you have is there two houses
involved or one
just one oh i got confused i'm sorry
okay
all right well i mean you you can do
whatever you want to do
obviously you're a grown man you call
and ask us what i would do
i think you're in a perilous situation
legally and relationally
and spiritually and so if i were you if
you were my little brother i put my arm
around you and say
saturday get married saturday
and celebrate new year's as an
anniversary of your wedding six months
from now
um and saturday because you
you are not what you you're trying to
act like with your finances that you're
married and
legally you're not so really what you
are is you own a home with your roommate
this is a partnership with no
partnership documents let me help you
with this
she dies in a car wreck you now own
and she doesn't have a will i know that
based on the way you all are acting
she dies in a car wreck you now own a
home with her mother and father
well that sucks right yeah
and this is the stuff i've gotten to
deal with over the last 30 years
it's the problem of uh setting up house
before you're married
because it sets you up and the other
thing is it sets up all kinds of
relational issues uh
because it's hard to combine money when
you're not
have not combined your thing so all of
that to say spiritually emotionally
financially everything else legally
i i i not real romantic but you already
you already cut your you already cut
your path here so
saturday i'd be married you know unless
it's
unless it's friday but chris what do you
want no i and and you were talking about
how do you keep your income steady what
line of work are you in
matthew i work in uh operation
manufacturing
actually i'm actually in grad school
currently finding my iba also okay
that's how you get your income so yeah i
mean you you want to be super
intentional uh with what you're doing um
as you're working and doing whatever you
have to do
but i agree with dave you all going to
get married getting focused being a true
team
uh and working together then you can be
in alignment and start to really set
goals together
uh i'd encourage you all both to go
through financial peace
uh once you get that situated get
plugged into the ramsey plus and
if you get married in the next 30 days
i'll gift it to you
i'll just give it to you anyway it's
your wedding gift
i was trying to motivate him i know but
okay you like santa
well i wasn't i wasn't in the first part
of the call so now i gotta be nice
you're soft now so that gone completely
interfered in his business
you gave him good guidance because
you're right he didn't call me about
that
but here's the reality him not
understanding that owning the house with
these
two people her parents that he has no
idea about him
to sell we've seen this he's going to be
legal fees no you're absolutely right it
is a financial nightmare
and so cautioning people out there just
to slow down people
slow down and think ahead yeah seriously
there's a study that talks about doing
things in the right order
and how that is an indicator of wealth
and it doesn't apply necessarily to
matthew's situation exactly
but the buying a house before you're
married together is in the wrong order
uh and because it can cause you so many
troubles and that's all i'm caring about
matthew i'm just trying to help you man
and if i got up in your grill too quick
i'm sorry but um
so but there they um
you know there's a whole poverty study
it talks about if you will graduate from
high school
before you get married or have a baby if
you will get married
before you have a baby though they call
that the success
lineage linkage and almost
all of your poverty data is when you get
those three things out of
whack out of order you start having
babies before high school grad
grad or you don't graduate high school
if you will graduate from high school
be over 20 21 years old before you get
married and
wait until then to have babies your
chances of being poverty go down like 94
whoa that's what the data shows so
it's uh i don't know if it's cause and
effect i'm not sure which one's causal
which one's the result but it's there